est-ce que c'est d'ailleurs pas est-ce
que c'est pas d'ailleurs justement sur
sur hollande on en voit d'ailleurs à
l'excellent dossier sur le figaro à lire
encore en kiosque aujourd'hui et sur
lefigaro.fr sur l'impossible retraite de
hollande est-ce que l'ancien président à
l'impopularité record qui s'opposent
est-ce que c'est même pas l'opposition
rêvée pour macron oui c'est sur quoi
qu'il faut se méfier parce qu'il peut il
peut aussi tapé où ça fait mal comme
d'ailleurs
wauquiez dans son interview au journal
du dimanche c'est qu'il va un peu sur le
terrain des manuels macron je pense que
c'est il joue une carte psychologie qui
veut le déstabiliser
il attaque justement en utilisant lui
qui est normalien alors qu emmanuel
macron en rater normale en le traitant
de rawa les miracles de bellamy en
parlant des airs de la météo et je pense
qu'il pense comme cela parce
qu'effectivement c'est pas faux il force
le trait mais c'est pas faux qu'il a un
ego surdimensionné comme d'ailleurs
beaucoup de présidents s'est pas fait ou
qu'il est chatouilleux sur ce sujet la
quine du mal à supporter la critique
donc je pense qu'il essaie de le faire
sortir de ses gonds
parce par ce biais là en utilisant
d'ailleurs dans cette interview j'étais
frappé quand vous dites emmanuel macron
parle comme louis parfois ils parlent
comme nous et comme comme parler sarkozy
par exemple mais parfois il nous parle
des passions tristes il nous parle de
littérature il ne parle pas toujours un
langage si si populaire que ça